i've known this guy for a very long time
you know i got to meet him when
nfl network started um he is one of
39 active or former nfl players and
coaches playing in the american century
celebrity championship and
uh in edgewood at edward tahoe in south
lake tahoe nevada we had
jay bilson's studio he's playing in it
uh we had tom glavin he's playing in it
yeah
why aren't we playing it great question
of our next guest here uh super bowl
champion uh
none other than joe theismann how are
you doing joe how you been
i'm great rich thank you and you know
you posed an interesting question i will
raise that to the committee
will you do that yeah what will you do
do you appear in front of the committee
joe is that where i would
i would i
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
now you need a description of the entire
committee and you know who i'm going to
go to
it's a great it's a great event i mean
you know annika is going to play this
year soren spam she's such a great
competitor okay catherine tappan's going
to be there
of course marty fish wanted last year
marty john smalls mark mulder tony romo
those
those
are probably the top four guys that'll
be competing and uh
you know to have the chance to play this
is the 32nd year
of the tournament i've played in 30 of
them
and just watch the way this thing grew a
couple years ago we didn't have
fans last year and it was a very limited
field but
two years ago they showed video about
what it was like in the first
times and you know our 17th hole at uh
edgewood
in lake tahoe is a lot like you see in
phoenix
on that par three sure um i really
almost think it's you know we started it
and
because you have the lake you have all
the boats lined up and everything else
and they're gonna be allowing fans this
year
so it's it's a it's a wonderful
experience and it's fun of course
charles will be there
yes um and a couple of years ago if i'm
not mistaken
uh sean payton gave new meaning to
hitting it off the deck uh
in golf literally i remember i remember
that a couple of years ago
oh yeah we did that guys that we've had
guys out in the boat out in the
uh you never know where somebody's going
to wind up in this tournament to be
honest with you whether it's in the
evening or during the day
during the tournament it's so it's an
awful lot of fun all right joe
we looked it up um go ahead chris what
what what does joe theismann uh
uh i know i know you don't have to say
it it's a lot okay
well no i'm not joe are you a two joe
since you're too handicapped
well they have music too i'm probably
closer to three and three five now
but it's been going up i'm so sorry i'm
terrible right now
i mean so sorry i'll apologize
oh my gosh i shoot three and a half and
you know off the tee on a on a par five
you know uh and i've got three more to
go joe that's that's my game
that's why i'm not invited maybe that's
me i'm not even competing oh not at all
you're
you're a huge personality you know i was
listening just to the interview a little
bit i think that was that a recorded
interview from a couple years ago what
was that yeah jane lynch yeah this
recorded a couple
i mean the thing was is um you are truly
uh
you know a man of vast knowledge uh
it doesn't make you it doesn't make you
geekish what it does is it makes you
very well-rounded
thank you a renaissance man thank you
now that's the way that's the way i
would describe it
renaissance i greatly appreciate that
joe theismann here uh no i mean
no i i know you do and i appreciate that
so uh
story of the nfl it's been a little
quiet though uh for the last couple of
weeks and
you know the next pressure point won't
be till training camp but what do you
think is going on with aaron rodgers
joe thought i think that i think aaron
has dug himself in
um at first when this thing happened of
course this goes back two years when the
with the drafting of uh jordan love
and that's a guy you have to feel bad
for because jordan's caught in the
middle of this thing he's the person
that the green bay packers moved up to
get a couple years ago when aaron felt
like they needed
other positions specifically wide
receiver and so he goes out and has an
mvp
year and basically i think what he's
saying you know in a non-verbal way
is look you thought so much about the
kids you went and moved up to go get
them uh you didn't give us what we what
i thought we needed
so if you wanted them you got them let
me go on and do something else except
the price
to get aaron and it it's it's
double-edged
the price that you pay for a guy of his
age
although i think he's got three or four
years great years left
but you what do you give up in a window
i mean if you're if you're close and you
think you're close to having a shot at
the championship
you'd consider it but if you're looking
at a team that's young and trying to
move forward i don't think you do it
because you have it's going to cost at
least two number ones
probably two number ones to number two
this is going to look like kevin costner
in drafting
okay he trades the three number ones and
he tries to get well you're not going to
get them back
but that's sort of what's going to wind
up happening i i
i would be surprised if he's a green bay
packer he's going to be in the
tournament too by the way
oh oh he is is he okay because there
patrick
holmes aaron is there justin timberlake
just to mention a few more sure
um you know so it's it
i i just uh there's too much of
too much has been said i think um
and i just couldn't understand the
organization a couple of months ago
come to packers coming out and saying
aaron rodgers
is our quarterback for the foreseeable
future are you kidding me
if if anything else i mean immediately
what i would have done with aaron is i
don't believe the last two years this
contractor guaranteed i guarantee his
contract
another given him a raise because he i
think he is undervalued
um not not as valued as i believe he
would be i mean
if you look at the numbers that some of
the guys are getting that haven't done
near as much as he is
i think he deserves uh more no i know
that
more than what he's getting the issue is
joe thoseman here on the rich eisen show
as you know as you pointed out to start
this is that it was the drafting of
jordan love that started a clock in this
day and age unlike
you know when you were drafted or as uh
you know
our friend terry bradshaw mentioned well
when i
you know they drafted mark malone i just
didn't pay that any mind well that's
because
you know mark malone's drafting in the
first round wasn't mandated
contractually in collective bargaining
uh contract
to put the kid out on the field right
away to see if you have to pick up a
second-year option that's the way things
go now so the drafting of love
how they drafted him and where they
drafted him started a clock and rogers
knows that
so my question and why they moved why
they moved
up together you know i had they drafted
when i 1982 or 83 they drafted tom flick
in the second round
when i behind me out of washington so
you know it's yeah i think it's really
hey can i mention something about
american century here though because
people
understand what american century
investments do i mean they're the
country's leading money manager for ets
mutual funds and retirement solutions
and they help clients achieve investment
goals that's who they are
but here's the thing that is so
wonderful about them too is
forty percent of american centuries
investment profits
go to the stour institute of medical
research that
uh that does research uh dedicated to
defeating life-threatening diseases
they have paid dividends of 1.7
billion dollars to the research to fight
it
think of a company that gives away forty
percent of its profits
to for charity and we've raised about
five and a half million up there in
tahoe in that area too
that's pretty close yeah yeah plus
there's gonna plus there's gonna be a uh
an opportunity to be a part of fantasy
golf
started a couple days ago i mean you can
participate in the american century golf
fantasy contest
pick five celebrities the best aggregate
performance wins all expense paid trip
to the 2022 tournament
and a ten thousand dollar donation to
the winner's charity of choice and all
you need to do is log on to www which i
don't need to say anymore uh
acc fantasygolf.com
and uh that's that's what makes this
this tournament so special we're you
know rich we're all competition junkies
those of us that have left together i
mean i i look i watch you i watch you
during the uh
during the draft i watch you run for
charity i mean
you're a lot you're a lot you're a lot
more explosive than people i think i
appreciate that joe
thank you thank you i appreciate that
that is an adjective that's not usually
attached to me and i greatly appreciate
you saying that
well it's not fast i mean explosive
that's true
that's another way words you can play
with i don't understand yes
i hear you i i read my scouting reports
joe you know i
i definitely read them you study them i
do
i do um so so you're going to head up
there soon i assume and you're
so do you know who are you paired with
do you know who you're paired with no we
won't know we won't get our pairing
sheets until i think
uh third wednesday or thursday night
then we'll figure out
how who we play i mean two three years
ago i played with alex smith and oddly
enough ryan fitzpatrick who both were
washington court one is a washington
quarterback
yes of course alex was one and i was
there and there's a chance alex is there
again
fitz is there again and i'll be there
again so there's a chance we might play
together
that's gonna be it joe we gotta have
that that's the way it's gonna be
college guys together
so you know i mean the pairings are fun
and uh
it's it's it's really uh it really is
i'll tell you for a guy that loves to
compete it's wonderful to challenge
yourself
uh anybody that plays the game of golf
knows how frustrating you can be now put
yourself in front of about four or five
thousand people oh forget it
um and take the club back and let's see
what you do exactly so so when you say
it's college pairing so it's you montana
and rudy is that who it is
well it's it could be over there notre
dame greats
you you montana and rudy and you know
only only two of you were on sides
that's the sort of thing
you never know
it's going to be though man i agree i
think that
this year has a chance i i've even more
than just i'll make this prediction
okay be like kerry this
this particular season will be the best
season in professional football that
we've seen
in recent history because of the young
players
guy like joe burrow coming back of
course you don't know what zach wilson's
going to do or trevor lawrence and then
then of course you know tom continues to
move on aaron i think we'll be somewhere
i think i can't see i just can't see him
sitting out of football right
um you know i think russell wilson you
know has sort of settled everything down
out in seattle and
uh you've got so many story lines
patrick is coming back you know they've
got
new guys at the tackle positions and you
know so many different
young blossoming stars dak coming back
off the
off the leg broken leg where will he be
in in the mix with the cowboys
i agree with you and joe after storyline
and then there's
uh you mentioned one and then you know
and then i'll let you go here
um i i think you know the team to beat
in the nfc east is the washington
football team and i'm not just saying
that because you're here
i love their defense they have a
defensive player of the year candidate
already uh i love how their defense last
year
uh i mean if they got their hands on you
they put you on the turf there were
there were really no yak
yards against that defense and right i
don't know i just you see so many
you know uh long-time veterans get a
shot
when so and i know that ryan fitzpatrick
frequently you know doesn't get
you know all 16 games in when he's been
named a starter
frequently but i i kind of like the mix
here i i think i've got a show
i think i think he would have gotten 16
in last year at miami and i made a
choice to go with to it right now
that wasn't because fitz wasn't playing
well correct that was because they just
wanted to make a change
i don't disagree with you i think this
football team can be special they added
speed to the wide receiver position they
had a depth of the tight end position
uh wayne jackson coming into the corner
position helps out tremendously
kendall fuller is back being able you
know coming from kansas city
and the thing is is the one thing that
jumped out at me though too in this
offseason
in this day and age of money grab it
really caught my eye
is very seldom do you see a championship
team
come back intact but yet the tampa bay
buccaneers i believe are returning all
22. they are last year and that was a
great defense last year
and they only really started to play to
their potential after the buy last year
and of course you know tom is going to
be top i mean the thing that he's been
able to do people wonder what's he able
to do
obviously takes care of himself and all
that stuff but his arm is good
as long as you have the ability to throw
the football you can
play this game a long time when the arm
goes that's the end of the business for
you
but i think tampa is another team that
you really really have to look at and
say wow
none of these guys left everybody i
think everybody wanted to be there
for one more shot at least one well tom
maybe two you never know right but i
agree with you on washington
now if i say it people go oh you're just
a homer you know
no you all you need to do is step back
and take a look at this this will be a
top three defense
for sure um i think you're right i think
so going forward and defense wins
championships no doubt
thanks for the call joe hit him straight
hit him straight in a couple weeks and
again
um the american century celebrity golf
championship
in tahoe on july 7th through 11th and
uh your new book how to be a champion
every day uh filled with all those
stories from
from your career uh available now
wherever you get your books
so thanks for the call joe rich thank
you i put a word in for you too
i appreciate that joe thank you you got
that we got a word being put in guys
joe thought that's cool hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here